first time moms can face so many
challenges with their newborn babies a
local speech pathologist is helping new
parents overcome feeding issues bianca
holman is live to explain interesting
that it's a
speech pathologist bianca tell us how
she became an expert in feeding problems
because i know a lot of moms are
probably need some good advice right now
yeah this is so important cheri when
new moms when they have issues they go
to their pediatrician or they go to the
hospital here uh but and they have all
the answers right well not quite when it
comes to infant feeding you may need to
check in with an infant feeding
specialist so we actually spoke with
kelly carter who is the owner of speak
easy therapy services she's not only a
speech pathologist but she's an expert
in infants feeding challenges bottle and
breastfeeding in two to six sessions she
gives new parents tools and tricks to
figure out why they're struggling and
also exercises to practice to fix the
issue and move forward if feeding issues
linger a baby could struggle with solid
food and ultimately not develop the way
they should carter says it can be
frustrating for new moms
if you don't have the
information you don't know what you
don't know and so it's hard to make
progress if you don't have it and the
goal is to get them from taking an hour
to feed to 15 minutes a feed should only
take 15 minutes and then have a three or
four hour gap so in the long term
getting the information and getting them
stronger will make will give them more
time
in addition carter sees other problems
like babies who are kept in carriers or
bundled up for long periods of time she
says parents should understand the baby
needs balance a free movement to
increase their strength and that's why
tummy time is so important and she says
oftentimes sometimes mom thinks it's
them it's they're the problem when
sometimes it just could be the
developmental issues with the child so
that's why where she steps in and helps
build those exercises so coming up in
the next half hour we're going to talk
about some red flags that you should pay
attention to if there are some issues
with feeding so we'll talk about that
coming up in the next half hour
reporting live bianca holman live local
now